when can the law stop you from saying
things about me in order to protect my
privacy pretty rarely it turns out here
are the five rules of free speech and
privacy actually before we get to the
rules let's just make clear what kind of
privacy we're talking about the Supreme
Court has sometimes discussed a right to
privacy but that's generally a right to
personal autonomy for instance the right
to buy and use contraceptives we're not
talking about that right here we also
often have a right to physical privacy
in the sense of freedom from trespass or
surveillance the Fourth Amendment for
example protects us against unreasonable
searches and seizures by the government
the law of trespass protects us against
physical intrusions by our neighbors the
tort of intrusion upon seclusion
protects us from other kinds of
surveillance such as people
photographing into our bedrooms using
high-powered magnifying lenses or people
telephoning us repeatedly in the middle
of the night we're not talking about
that here either rather we're talking
about informational privacy restrictions
on your communicating information about
me when I think that information is
highly private now on to the rules rule
one we usually have the right to speak
about other people not just about ideas
we can express opinions about them even
if those opinions are insulting we can
say true things about them even when
they'd rather keep that information
private newspapers and TV programs are
chock full of speech about people many
of whom would rather not be spoken about
the same is true of biographies even
autobiographies usually reveal
information not just about the writer
but about his family friends lovers
business associates and more rule two we
have a near absolute right to reproduce
information drawn from government
records newspapers can quote arrest
records or documents from court cases
even when they describe the private
details of the defendants life or of a
victim's life for instance in 1989 the
Supreme Court struck down a statute that
forbade the media from publishing the
names of sex offense victims such a
statute the court held wrongly limited
the right to publish information drawn
from government records such as arrest
reports and this right doesn't vanish
with time there can be no european-style
right to be forgotten under American law
at least when it comes to material taken
from government records rule 3 our free
speech rights extend to speech about
private figures and not just about
government officials or famous people
indeed newspaper stories often this
close information about ordinary people
who have never sought publicity rule for
lower courts have allowed some civil
lawsuits for so-called public disclosure
of private facts the Supreme Court has
never decided whether this torte is
constitutionally valid but even if the
torte can be constitutional courts
agreed that it's sharply limited first
it only applies to revelations of highly
embarrassing or personal information
such as sexual history or medical
conditions second it's limited to
statements that aren't newsworthy that's
a vague line but courts have read the
newsworthiness defense quite broadly so
long as the facts are linked to
newsworthy events such as crime people
are free to repeat them third as rule to
notes
material borrowed from government
records again such as trial transcripts
or arrest reports can pretty much always
be published rule 5 the strongest
protection for privacy is generally
contract if a business for instance
promises not to disclose information
about its customers that promise can be
enforced in court same if for instance
someone who is working for a celebrity
signs a nondisclosure agreement as a
condition of employment such contracts
aren't always enforceable for instance
if a court orders you to disclose
information about a customer you can't
just insist that you had promised the
customer to keep it secret likewise a
federal statute bars businesses from
requiring consumers to sign
non-disparagement clauses in which the
consumer promises not to publish
critical reviews of the business but if
a contract not to speak is otherwise
enforceable the First Amendment doesn't
prevent its enforcement and that extends
to promises of privacy as well as to
other non-disclosure agreements so to
sum up we usually have the right to
speak about other people the right to
publish information from government
records is nearly absolute and doesn't
vanish with time our free speech rights
extend to speech about private figures
and not just government officials or
famous people lower courts have allowed
some civil lawsuits for public
disclosure of private facts but the
Supreme Court has never decided whether
this is constitutionally valid and the
strongest protection for privacy is
generally contract this is not legal
advice if this were legal advice it
would be followed by a bill please use
responsibly written by Eugene Bullock
who is an actual real-life First
Amendment law professor at UCLA I'm
Eugene Baalak and I approve
[Music]